[Music]
we jump from what women want to see to
what men won which is literally the name
of taraji P Henson's new movie and I was
first on the set in Atlanta what am I
thinking right now you are thinking how
lucky you are to be standing next to me
on the set of my new movie what men want
you read my you are incredible can you
hear my inner thoughts in the comedy
taraji plays a sports agent being held
back by the boys club called Dre at work
until she hits her head and wakes up
with a special gift she can hear what
men are thinking thank god this one's in
dying on me
starting today no more drinking at work
hey that's too much information anything
if the plot sounds familiar it is what
men want comes from the same studio who
released the Mel Gibson hit what women
want nearly 18 years ago would fall for
a guy at work don't fall for a guy in
black why my watch taraji 'he's new
movies inspired by the 2000 hit and
marks her first leading role in a
romantic comedy this is what I worked my
entire career for this moment right here
I didn't even have to audition would you
be afraid to know what men really are
thinking yes I think some things you I
don't need to know everything I like to
leave things left I need things left to
the imagination what you're seriously
the dumb in advice I can at least wish
and imagine that they're smart the dump
man I know
by the way taraji got engaged in May to
former NFL star Kelvin AMA Haden so we
know what taraji wanted and she got it
you
[Music]